bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france c'est donc qu'il me
semble la deuxième rencontre du groupe
au congo depuis le début de l'année
qu'elles sont allées point d'étape qui
sont envisagées pour une résolution de
la crise en libye
tout d'abord c'est une étape
supplémentaire et importante en 2011
l'union africaine s'est fait subtiliser
la décision la majeure la plus
déterminante et malheureusement depuis
la libye les libyens vivent le chaos
mais pas seulement les libyens et une
bonne partie de l'afrique et notamment
le sahel et à reçoit toutes les
conséquences donc d'une décision qui
internationale qui a échappé
malheureusement à l'union africaine qui
n'a pas eu le dernier mot
donc là il ya une décision qui a été
prise donc pour une intervention est
plutôt un colloque une conférence
libyenne nationale internationale
intervienne avec tous les belligérants
pour que cesse déjà d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'au mois de juillet parce que le
mois de juillet sera le mois de cette
conférence à addis abeba lieu du siège
de l'union africaine pour qu'il y ait
plus qu'une réconciliation qu'il ya des
discussions juro stratégique
géopolitique pour aller vers la paix le
groupe de contact de l'union africaine à
la volonté de créer un dialogue inclusif
qui impliquerait toutes les parties
prenantes dans le conflit libyen comment
un peuvent-ils s'y prendre
nous sommes quelque peu dans l'impasse
la libye est coupée en deux voir en 3
donc il va falloir que toutes les
parties soient des parties prenantes
écouter à égalité et pas seulement en
terme de force frappe de puissance
géopolitique intérieur donc savez tous
le tout les négociations à partir de à
partir de ceux de ce 13 mars jusqu'au
mois que jusqu'au mois de juillet et en
espérant que les os et les violations
sur l'embargo sur les armes et les
influences et les ingérences en dehors
du continent cesse et il laisse
notamment les libyens vivre autrement
que dans le chaos est dans l'impasse y
compris pour les migrants qui se
trouvent dans des situations
de manière spectaculaire
extraordinairement effroyable argens à
des états occidentaux non respect des
accords sur les armes ce sont les
revendications majeures du groupe de
contact à quelles sont en quelques mots
les intérêts des parties prenantes dans
le conflit libyen mais ce que ce que
disent les pays africains c'est clair
que une communauté internationale tous
les pays d'afrique font partie de la
communauté internationale souvent qu'on
parle de la communauté internationale
ont l'impression que les pays africains
ne font pas partie de la communauté
internationale
l'afrique du nord au sein de l'afrique
du nord il ya la libye tous les pays du
maghreb et de l'afrique de l'afrique du
nord sont des pays africains souvent pas
de la fri et du maghreb malheureusement
dans la même phrase alors que tous les
pays du maghreb sont en a fait donc ce
que les pays africains disent c'est
qu'ils veulent gagner en crédibilité et
en est en respectabilité en légitimité
et que qu'ils puissent être entendus et
avoir le dernier mot sur le plan
international et que ce ne soit pas des
puissances étrangères au continent qui
encore le dernier mot parce que les
conséquences et les évêques et les
effets sont pour le peuple libyen et les
pays africains autour qui sont
malheureusement dans une dans une rose
bleu jaune rouge depuis depuis 2011
il faut et cours il faut écouter les
expertises ils viennent donc africaine
il faut écouter les expertises de
l'union africaine
mais il ne pas seulement dire et
entendre avoir des recettes extérieures
au continent et on ne veut pas que que
l'afrique et notamment la libye soit le
laboratoire d'élite géostratégiques et
géopolitiques qui dépasse le continent
africain
voilà pourquoi avec force et a été donc
presque réanimer réaffirmé par
l'ensemble de ces 54 pays qui ont été
représentés notamment par le nouveau
président de l'union africaine le
président de l'afrique du sud afrique du
sud séverine ramaphosa merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions jean claude félix tchicaya je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'ehess